how you doing season three season three
how amazing is that I will say grief
looks nice this season he's brief is uh
is holding up he's holding his own and
he's wearing some really cool looking
clothes in season three too he looks
like he's doing better than ever he's
thriving his skin is glowing you know
what he's a man who is uh Living Well
eating right taking the good medications
not the bad medications and having a lot
of fun in what he's doing yeah I love
the scene where you just have a girl
who's spinning in the chair while you're
that kid is just incorrigible he won't
stop he steals every scene so if you
have a conversation and grogo is
anywhere around it's like having that
toddler that you're constantly saying
get out off there don't do
fun with grow good what is grief up to
besides uh living well this season uh I
think his bank account is growing so
that's always nice grief is now
um really running I think a city that is
like really growing and coming into its
own and uh watching out you know of
course for all those bad guys who come
in and try to take over and as you will
find
he's really trying to find a way to
entice uh
um din Jaron to come back
come back join him work for me huh does
it work for me ah you know I not so
necessarily work for me work with me yes
you've directed some fantastic episodes
of this show are you back in the
director's chair again this season I am
I am and so happy to be back thank you
for asking
I mean this show just gets better and
better how do you describe season three
and how it compares to the other two
seasons so far
wow it's a really good question I think
bigger and better
uh John Favreau de faloni just keep
man they just keep throwing it down you
know and all of us in front of the
camera and those of us who are have the
Good Fortune working behind the camera
and directing are just doing our best
just to keep up and to you know honor
what these guys are putting down and
certainly John is just
doing a magnificent job magnificent job
so I'm a very fortunate guy to be a part
of it hope it never ends that makes two
of us thanks so much pleasure
foreign